c'est l'histoire d'une école mythique
une école connu de tous et qui alimente
les fantasmes
quand je me présente
des repas ou à des soirées dans ma vie
privée avec je dis que je prépare les
nas certains me disent mais devrait
devenir président de la république
l'école nationale d'administration a
formé quatre présidents de la république
neuf premiers ministres des dizaines de
ministres et grands patrons quelques
7000 haut fonctionnaire elle est devenue
synonyme de pouvoir
pourtant au départ l'école créée au
sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale
n'était pas fait pour ça elle a été
pensée pour former des serviteurs de
l'état
cette école c'est un idéal d'excellence
au profit de la république
mais au fil du temps quelque chose se
grippe
entre soi conformisme
école tremplin pour faire carrière en
politique ou dans le privé
léna et les énarques sont accusés de
tous les maux
il ya un problème avec une partie de ce
que les nav produits comment l'école
nationale d'administration
fondée sur des idéaux humanistes et
républicains est elle devenue cette
école que les français adorent détester
les normes at elle connu des dérives et
à quel moment
at elle vraiment démérité
[Musique]
1936 léon blum arrive au pouvoir
c'est le front populaire de grandes
réformes sociales sont votés congés
payés semaine de 40 heures
mais ce gouvernement a aussi un autre
projet moins connus qui lui tient à
coeur
créer une école d'administration
car au milieu des années trente la haute
fonction publique pose problème
elle est aux mains d'une caste de
notables son recrutement est
antidémocratique
avant l'ena la haute fonction publique
elles étaient recrutés directement par
les employeurs les corps les ministères
ou par des concours qui étaient des
concours spécifiques à chaque corps le
ctd concours dont chacun savait qu'ils
étaient un petit peu magouilles et
disons que lorsqu'on était le fils le
neveu ou le frère d'un membre du jury on
avait toutes les chances d'intégrer on
cite toujours le fait que autrefois
avant l'ena le l'oral de recrutement
l'inspection des finances se passait
dans la salle à manger du ministre et
donc il y avait un risque de cooptation
d'un flux en conséquence beaucoup de
fonctionnaires ne sont pas au niveau
un homme est particulièrement choqués
par cette situation
jean zay le nouveau ministre de
l'éducation
avocat de formation quel enfant du
peuple a jamais pu être ambassadeur
s'interroge-t-il
aucun essai bien problème pour y
remédier jean et veut créer une école
nationale d'administration
pour moi quand on me demande de l'ena
web
c'est ça les nas etc ça c'est l'enfant
du peuple c'est la base même de la
république qui peut accéder aux plus
hautes fonctions ambassadeur c'est
l'utopie républicaine dont on essaie
qu'elle rentre dans le réel
jean zay veut aussi créer une
administration qui sera profondément
républicaines car il le pressent en cas
de péril les hauts fonctionnaires ne
défendront pas la république la
république a besoin d' assises solides
parce qu'elle a toujours des ennemis il
faut pas oublier que nous sommes dans
les années 30 et que c'est l'époque de
la montée des fascismes dont il faut une
administration recrutés sur des critères
strictement républicain en août 1936
joseph est passé à l'assemblée un projet
de loi créant une école d'administration
mais les choses traînent le sénat bloque
bientôt l'heure n'est plus aux grandes
réformes
[Musique]
le fascisme au progresse partout en
europe
ils veulent à précipiter dans la guerre
en mai 1940 hitler lance son offensive
éclair
[Musique]
les chars allemands enfonce les lignes
françaises dans les ardennes
appelé à la rescousse le maréchal pétain
choisi de se rendre là le coeur serré
que je vous dise aujourd'hui qu'il faut
cesser le combat
je fais à la france le don de ma
personne aurait fait mieux en valeur
derrière pétant une bonne partie du pays
se résigne à la défaite puis à la
collaboration
c'est la fin de la république et le
début du régime de vichy un régime
réactionnaire antirépublicain antisémite
comme jean zay le redoutait la majorité
de la haute fonction publique tourne le
dos à la république et soutient le
maréchal comme ces préfets en 1943
l'hôtel de ville de vichy le maréchal
pétain réunit tous les préfets de france
pour recevoir leur serment de fidélité
monsieur carle préfet du nord prononcée
au nom des fonctionnaires unis la
formule de cernon quand on regarde de
près le comportement des administrations
en france c'est concernant ils y sont
allés quoi ils sont paysans
il ya très peu de il ya eu très peu de
résistance dans ces administrations la
refuse
c'est combien de magistrats n'ont pas
prêté serment à vichy jean zay lui
choisi la résistance mais le 15 août
1940 il est arrêté par la police de
vichy et emprisonnés du fond de sa
cellule il a réfléchi aux raisons pour
lesquelles les hauts fonctionnaires ont
capitulé si vite et se sont compromis
tandis que son épouse et ses filles
vient lui rendre visite
il fait passer en cachette c'est écrit
dans le landeau d'hélène de son écriture
soignée serré pour économiser le papier
jean zay on arrive à cette conclusion
implacable la république a payé du
reniement des hauts fonctionnaires l'une
de ses plus fâcheuses défaillance elle
avait négligé de surveiller leur
recrutement d'assurer elle-même leur
formation ils ne l'ont pas défendu et
donc cette analyse là de la défaite de
1940 le conforte évidemment dans ce cas
était son intuition de départ sa volonté
de départ qui était de former des hauts
fonctionnaires non seulement du point de
vue de l'égalité de tous mais aussi de
recruter des gens qui ont cette fois
républicaine et cet engagement
républicain mais j'en ai n'aura pas le
temps de voir son projet se concrétiser
il sera assassiné par la milice en 1944
deux mois après l'assassinât de jean zay
paris libéré le peuple exulte
mais après la liesse vient le temps des
règlements de compte
m
les politiques mais aussi les
fonctionnaires qui ont servi le régime
de vichy sont jugés de payer
pour se reconstruire le pays à des gens
de 9
[Applaudissements]
de gaulle à la tête du gouvernement
provisoire demande alors à michel debré
de réformer la fonction publique
docteur en droit michel debré connaît
bien l'administration
il reprend l'idée de jean zay et en
avril 45 pour la première fois il
propose général de créer l'hymne
le général dit à mon père alors parlez
moi de l'administration et de l'école
que vous voulez créer mon père dit en
france il y à des écoles pour former les
officiers les sous-officiers les
instituteurs les professeurs y a pas
d'école pour former les fonctionnaires
les hauts fonctionnaires de gaulle
comprend immédiatement tout l'intérêt
qu'il y a créé une école
d'administration
elle offrira à l'état un vivier de
fonctionnaires compétents et intègres
dans lequel puiser six mois plus tard le
9 octobre 1945
lena voit le jour
[Musique]
dans la foulée le corps des
administrateurs civils est créé il doit
être unifiée la haute fonction publique
avec lui les élèves sortis de l'ena
peuvent passer d'une administration à
l'autre
nous avons tous connu ce fonctionnaire
qu'on retrouvait dans toutes les
administrations ce fonctionnaire vieilli
sous leur nez tout cela a changé pour
former ces hauts fonctionnaires la
quatrième république possède maintenant
son école d'administration
démocratisation et méritocratie sont au
rendez vous
lena sélectionnera les meilleurs quelle
que soit leur origine
l'école ouvre ses portes aux femmes en
1946 les premières d'entre elles sont
reçus au concours les fonctionnaires des
chenaux modestes peuvent aussi tenter
leur chance pour recruter les élèves de
l'ena on prévoit deux concours un
concours d'étudiants qui seront formés
par les instituts d'études politiques
qui sont créés aussi en 45 et un
concours de fonctionnaires parce qu'on
ne veut pas que des fonctionnaires de
qualité qui sont dans les ministères ou
qui sont dans les préfectures puisse
penser qu'ils ne peuvent pas monter
c'est l'ouverture républicaines et
démocratiques wee cc profondément
révolutionnaire est profondément nouveau
auto et cas à l'époque
l'amour de la république est au coeur du
projet de l'énorme le premier directeur
henri bourdeau de fontenay est un
résistant
chaque année ils emmènent les élèves
ranimer la flamme sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu
et pour donner le ton la première
promotion est baptisé france combattante
[Musique]
les trois premières promotions elles
sont choisies de façon assez
particulière
il faut avoir été déporté résistant aux
prisonniers de guerre et donc on choisit
des personnes qui ont vécu la guerre
dont le caractère s'est forgée sans
doute pendant cette période et qui ont
envie de bâtir quelque chose de nouveau
ils ont donc presque de sentiments ses
premières promotions de servir une cause
qui les dépasse
une sorte de transe en danse qui n'est
pas religieuse mais qui républicaine
avec tout le sens du mot république res
publica c'est la chose publique c'est
l'idée que la démocratie doit s'appuyer
sur un état fort
socialement ouverts et énergiques après
six années de guerre
le pays est en ruine
les premières promotions sortie de l'ena
participe activement à sa reconstruction
dans une économie planifiée
ces hauts fonctionnaires sont aux
manettes et pilotes de grands projets
alors que la quatrième république est
instable politiquement ils en sont les
piliers avec eux lena démarre en fanfare
de gaulle lui voit le pouvoir lui
échapper
il va connaître une traversée du désert
qui va durer douze ans en 1958 après le
putsch d'alger
il est rappelé sur le devant de la scène
les aux foules qui l'acclament le
général prévient il ne reviendra qu'à la
condition de créer une cinquième
république avec la musique utile fort
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de répondre
[Musique]
le référendum pour une nouvelle
constitution est un raz-de-marée de
gaulle qui attendaient ce moment depuis
1946 est enfant en chef de l'état
2 me
avec son retour lena va devenir une arme
au service du pouvoir
quand de gaulle revient au pouvoir sir
concrètement quand il prend ses
fonctions de président de la république
en 1918 1959 il trouve tout près la
l'outil qu'il avait forgé en 1944 1945
pour un gouvernement fort et le
gouvernement fort et là les institutions
de la vème république sont là et donc de
gaulle à cet outil à sa disposition
[Musique]
pendant dix ans les hauts fonctionnaires
sortie de l'ena concerne le pouvoir
gaulliste
ils sont partout dans les ministères et
les administrations
mais au fil du temps ils n'ont plus
grand chose à voir avec la promo de
résistants de 1946 la france vit au
rythme des trente glorieuses on pense
consommation réussite sociale pour les
20 ans de l'école un reportage montre
que les élèves de l'ina assume désormais
sans rougir de vouloir conquérir le
pouvoir
deux jeunes loups aux dents longues
la grande responsabilité dans la france
voici que voilà composition particulier
regarder alors il est différent
directeur de cabinet me pointe dans
toute l'année vous avez marre il ya un
idéaliste au départ il ya aussi un avis
il est assez longue mais tant le pouvoir
l'argent le pouvoir serait sans doute
passé ce changement de logique fait
grincer des dents notamment celle de
pierre mendès-france
pour cet ancien résistant principales
figures de la gauche à l'époque
lena connaît une dérive dans la presse
il dénonce ces jeunes messieurs content
d'eux est avide de pouvoir
[Musique]
en cette fin des années 60 les n'est
donc sous le feu de la critique
et bientôt ce sont les élèves eux mêmes
qui s'en prennent à leur ancienne école
notamment un certain jean pierre
chevènement 28 ans déjà rebelle nous
pensons qu'il faut donner un petit coup
de pied dans la fourmilière et trois
camarades
alain gomez d'immochan et moi-même nous
nous partageons le travail
chacun fait un chapitre on trouve le
titre l'énarchie qui est un sobriquet de
dérision énarchie énarque chevènement et
ses camarades invente deux mots qui vont
entrer dans l'histoire
et même dans le dictionnaire
tout ça c'est très moqueur
ça va être repris ensuite on est énarque
aujourd'hui comme on les barons baron
lempire bien marquis sous l'ancien
régime
c'est ridicule chevènement et sa bande
font le procès de leur école ils lui
reprochent son manque de mixité sociale
située rue de l'université à paris dans
les beaux quartiers
lena est fréquentée par la jeunesse
dorée
[Musique]
fils d'instituteur et boursiers jean
pierre chevènement est une exception
il se sent mal à l'aise nous élèverons
ressemble aux petits messieurs que je
connus à sciences po qui sont que
c'était des jeunes gens de bonne famille
il s'acharnait déjà à l'âge de 18 ans à
ressembler à leurs pdg de père pas
manqué de fantaisie ce qu'avait déjà
relevé jean pierre chevènement et ses
amis au milieu des années 60 c'est que
il y avait eu un rétrécissement
sociologique c'est à dire que ce qui
était là l'ambition de l'ena au
lendemain naguère d'aller puiser
largement dans toutes les ressources du
pays
eh bien ça s'était perdu en chemin autre
grief jean pierre chevènement critique
le classement de sortie à la fin de leur
scolarité les élèves passent un concours
qui détermine leur carrière en fonction
de leurs résultats
il choisissait un corps de la fonction
publique trois d'entre eux sont
particulièrement prestigieux
le conseil d'état l'inspection des
finances et la cour des comptes
on les appelle les grands corps il
existe depuis plus de deux siècles et
son tout-puissant seulement sur une
centaine d'élèves
seuls les premiers arrivés dans la botte
c'est à dire entre 12 et 20 seulement
les promotions peuvent y accéder
alors cette botte du monde en rêve car
c'est la promesse d'un avenir radieux
la botte c'est l'illusion qu'on va faire
une superbe carrière et le système est
monté mais depuis très tôt dans
l'illusion que on va décrocher la
timbale bien il ya un côté manège avec
la queue du mickey eto'o et qu'il faut
décrocher la caractéristique d'un grand
corps c'est de propulser très vite très
jeune leurs membres à des positions de
responsabilité à des postes de direction
dans l'administration centrale au sein
des cabinets ministériels et même en
dehors de l'état je vais peut-être souks
et mélina ne compte que pour les grandes
encore c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
qu'on nous dit qu'elle quelqu'un vous
êtes sûre si l'inspection des finances
tout de suite vous c'est on sait ce que
ça veut dire vous êtes le meilleur
si au moment où vous prépariez l'ena
vous aviez eu la certitude que vous
sortiriez dans la dernière partie du
classement c'est à dire comme seriez
administrateur civil
est ce que vous vous auriez fait l'ena
bien je pense que la question est en
pause et de cette manière je te
répondrais que non mais vous monsieur
moi je ne pense pas non plus et vous
n'en n'ont pas une pensée ça je vois
pour nom à coup sûr non
par les possibilités de carrière
vertigineuse qu'ils offrent les grands
corps apparaisse comme nouvelle noblesse
du temps
pour mettre fin à cette course effrénée
au classement et rééquilibrer les choses
au sein de la haute administration
chevènement et ses camarades suggère une
solution
nous proposons la suppression du
recrutement des grands corps à la sortie
de l'école nous proposons que les grands
corps soit recruté quelques années plus
tard peut-être 7,8 en dix ans après nous
pensons que il est possible d'aller plus
loin dans la démocratisation
la solution fait débat mais fait surtout
germer des idées dans la tête des élèves
des promo suivante
d'autant que mai 68 éclate
l'heure est à la révolte
[Applaudissements]
si les nouvelles recrues de l'ena ne
sont pas sur les barricades un vent de
fronde souffle sur l'école
bientôt 68 élèves de la promotion
charles de gaulle annonce qu'il refuse
le classement de sortie
il veut choisir une carrière en fonction
de leurs aspirations
certains élèves ont remis cette
hiérarchie en question un des mystères
qui était moins valorisés oms les
plupart des gens bien classés comme les
affaires culturelles d'autorité un peu
plus délaissés et ils vont ensemble chez
chose qui est favorable même si pour ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est un sacrifice qui
est réel dans l'état actuel des choses
nous aussi on vous proposait un carrosse
et vous avez pris une petite cylindrée
pourquoi j'ai en effet choisi
l'inspection des affaires sociales
plutôt que l'inspection des finances
c'est un choix personnel
je ne regrette absolument pas même le
major décide de devenir préfet pourtant
une poignée d'élèves ne jouent pas le
jeu
car les grands corps reste un aimant
puissant et depuis quelques temps leur
pouvoir d'attractivité d'autant plus
grand qu'ils ouvrent les portes du monde
politique
[Musique]
1974 lena connaît un nouveau tournant
désormais l'école va être associé aux
carrières politiques
cette année là pour la première fois un
énarque accède au plus haut sommet de
l'état valéry giscard d'estaing sortie
sixième du classement alors valéry
giscard d'estaing est un énarque
singulier
car en réalité il fait partie de ces
polytechniciens qui ont les possibilités
de sortir enfin de faire une scolarité à
l'ena à l'issue de polytechnique
giscard s'entoure d'énarques son premier
ministre d'abord jacques chirac lui
aussi issus des grands corps
tous deux recrute un nombre
impressionnant d'anciens de l'école qui
font alors leur entrée au gouvernement -
cabinet
la france semble tomber aux mains des
énarques dans la presse la polémique
enfle
l'école nationale d'administration est
devenu en quelque sorte synonyme d'école
du pouvoir le président de la république
ses hommes de confiance à l'elysée le
premier ministre jacques chirac deux
ministres michel poniatowski jean pierre
fourcade quatre secrétaires d'état une
dizaine de directeurs de cabinet et plus
de 70 conseillers techniques et chargés
de mission sur 200 sortes de l'école de
la rue des saints pères
bref c'est le temps des états c'est là
où on a le sentiment que l'école a
changé de vocation
elle était faite pour former des
administrateurs on découvre que l'effort
fait pour former des des ministes des
produits mise et même des prisons de la
république
ce qui d'ailleurs est une vision
déformée de l'ena parce que c'est vrai
que ça a eu cette conséquence mais
malgré tous les élèves de l'ena ils sont
pas tous présidents premiers ministres
ministres même à cette époque beaucoup
sont des administrateurs qui servent
l'état et qui n'ont pas d'engagement
politique particulier aux avant-postes
en politique les anarque deviennent de
plus en plus visible ils vont être
d'autant plus critique
surtout quand ces années 70
le visage de technocrates à commencer
par le président lui-même bonsoir madame
brosseau vanoise elle bonsoir monsieur
avec son élocution jugée hautaine sont
français châtié et ses explications
savantes mans giscard ne tarde pas à
être assimilé à une caricature de
technocrates ses causeries au coin du
feu avec son petit tableau n'êtes pas à
changer son image
il s'agit là de la production en termes
physiques des quantités produits
comment se situe le chiffre de la france
il faut 1974
notre croissance aura été de 4 et demi
pour sow c'est vrai qu' il peut y avoir
une technocratisation de la fonction
politique et on le voit à travers le
langage on le voit à travers les les
les priorités souvent très économique et
social assez peu sociétale même s'il
valéry giscard d'estaing essaie de
réhabiliter travail ouvrier même si à
simone veil qui va faire la loi sur sur
les vg et c'est vrai qu'il y aille à
l'engager technocratique qui s'installe
dans la politique
pour les français cette approche froide
et techniques du monde est vite assimilé
à une déconnexion les énarques ne
comprendrez rien aux problèmes de la
population
car depuis peu le pays est en souffrance
le choc pétrolier de 1973 a sonné le
glas des trente glorieuses les français
découvrent le chômage et la vie chère
ça nous donne d'abord parce que tout au
monde
je suis comme sylvain notre salaire
n'augmente pas mais sur les nuques
risque face à la crise les énarques
deviennent les coupables idéaux
puisqu'ils sont partout dans les
administrations les ministères se sont
forcément eux les responsables pour les
30 ans de l'ena un nouveau reportage en
dit long sur l'état d'esprit de l'école
technocrates coupés des réalités
humaines jeune bourgeoise ambitieux
privilégiés sélectionnés selon leur
origine sociale fonctionnaires
quelquefois incompétent et toujours
arrogant l'opinion publique les jugent
sévèrement l'ena prépare-t-elle des
hauts fonctionnaires particulièrement
compétent ou bien est-elle qu'un moule
ton sort une fausse élite une élite à
laquelle on reproche encore et toujours
son endogamie les élèves sont presque
tous issus d'un milieu favorisé dit
encore fils de professeurs de
l'université martine aubry fi des hauts
fonctionnaires
isabelle bouillot qui le directeur de
société là bas je les fais ingénieurs
elizabeth duke ce pan fille de salariés
louis mermaz fils de représentant de
commerce le climat est tel qu aux
législatives de 1978
un syndicat de petits commerçants
dirigée par gérard nicoud appelle à
voter pour n'importe qui sauf pour un
énarque et partir du moment où vous
donnez à l'état le visage et l'identité
d'une école par ce moment l'ena est
devenu l'incarnation de l'état alors que
beaucoup de hauts fonctionnaires ne sont
pas issus de l'ena réalité mais li na
est devenue une sorte de projection
physiques visibles palpables facile à
identifier à cibler de l'état c'est
normal qu'on n'aime pas les normes il ya
toujours eu dans ce pays et dans
d'autres
un discours anti élites et anti état ils
font l'ena c'est la conjonction des deux
méta limites
trente ans après la création de l'école
les énarques commence à être détesté
pourtant ils sont devenus indispensables
au fonctionnement de l'état cet état
qu'il incarne
malgré eux françois mitterrand est élu
président de la république mai 1981 la
gauche arrive à l'elysée giscard cède la
place mitterrand n'est pas énarque mais
avocat de formation il n'a rien d'un
technocrate lui est un littéraire la
politique à ses yeux c'est avant tout
des idées et des symboles dont il s'est
ouvert à merveille mitterrand a promis
de réformer la france
alors pour y parvenir comme giscard et
de gonâve ennuis il s'entoure d'énarques
plus que ses prédécesseurs encore le
nouveau président socialiste a besoin de
ces hauts fonctionnaires rouages
décidément incontournable du pouvoir
c'est pas une chope et c'est une
nécessité
la gauche arrive aux responsabilités du
pays
après
23 ans d'opposition la gauche est dans
une situation économique très difficile
la gauche a besoin de crédibilité de
légitimité mitterrand apporte la
légitimité de l'élection mais il a
besoin de crédibilité
il a besoin que le pays soit soit sûr
que il va être dirigé par des gens qui
ont moins la connaissance de l'état
la compétence pour le gérer c'est le
programme commun de la gauche
c'est une vision très étatiste donc en
réalité pour les nas avoir une
conséquence c'est que jamais l'état ne
vais aussi présent dans la vie
économique et sociale qu pendant les
premières années du mitterrandisme et
donc jamais les énarques ne vont être
aussi présent aux commandes
ces énarques qui entourent mitterrand ce
sont d'abord ces socialistes qui ont
permis la victoire
michel rocard lionel jospin jean-pierre
chevènement laurent fabius
ce sont aussi de jeunes talents
prometteurs comme le couple ségolène
royal et françois hollande tous deux ont
été recrutés par jacques attali
conseiller spécial de mitterrand et
énarque sortie au conseil d'état
aussitôt en place mitterrand applique le
programme commun de la gauche
il donne le coup d'envoi à sa mesure
économique phare les nationalisations
je pense nécessaire nationalisation d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises vinh design
le 13 février 1982 la loi sur les
nationalisations et promulgué la
décision provoque un tremblement de
terre dans l'économie française
quarante quatre groupes industriels et
financiers sont finalement nationalisé à
leur tête on trouve de nombreux énarque
qui enfile le costume de grand patron
comme jean yves à braire qui prend la
direction de paribas ou alain gomez
celle de thomson cette mule contre
nature des hauts fonctionnaires en chef
d'entreprise fait naître un nouvel enjeu
celui de leur rémunération très vite
dans la presse la question est sur
toutes les lèvres qu'on veut bien vont
gagner ses nouveaux patrons qui vont
s'asseoir dans des fauteuils qui
jusqu'ici étaient parmi les plus dorée
de france
d'après ce que l'on peut savoir leurs
salaires ont aussi entre 40000 et 60
mille francs par mois trois à cinq fois
plus que dans la fonction publique et ce
n'est qu'un début
les salaires vont bientôt s'envoler la
cote des énarques explose dans le même
temps l'argent est célébré comme une
nouvelle valeur ce sont les années fric
cette chaire est reggane domine le monde
la pensée néolibérale s'impose
en france la figure de l'entrepreneur
incarné par bernard tapie voit le jour
la réussite individuelle se mesure
désormais à son compte en banque
un contexte qui a évidemment une
incidence sur l'ena certains élèves
commencent à douter de leur choix parmi
eux mêmes les mules ce jeune élève
prodige manuel avant les nains mais neil
buhne centre d'abord à polytechnique à
17 ans après avoir eu son bac à 14
cela lui vaut de participer à un
reportage sur les surdoué en 1978 j'ai
un petit peu gêné devant les caméras
c'est la première fois que fut filmée je
vous profité pour dire bonjour à nos
parents
quatre ans plus tard en 1982 manuel munz
intègre l'ena promotion louise michel
mais la conviction n'y est pas
les bars comme certains de ses camarades
en 16 années 80 manuel mais il se
demande si l'administration pourra lui
offrir une carrière à la hauteur de ses
espérances
je ne suis pas rentrer à l'ena pour être
fonctionnaire je suis rentré à l'ena
pour continuer mes études tout en étant
payés et en préservant la toutes les
possibilités
il y avait des gens qui voulaient être
fonctionnaire et puis avec des gens qui
voulaient que c'était lui qui comme moi
voulait juste réussir dans la vie quoi
tout simplement c'était vous voulez
réussir c'est une façon de parler mais
en tout cas qui qui s'imaginait pas être
fonctionnaire toute leur vie grâce à ses
oeuvres à cette époque où l'argent est
devenu roi
certains élèves de l'ena assume de
vouloir gagner plus et tourne le dos à
l'état
en 1984 25 d'entre eux dont manuel
minutes publiée dans le monde une
petites annonces provocatrices
offrez-vous un énarque il appelle les
entreprises privées aller débaucher à
leur sortie de l'école
le mois suivant nous avons entre 24 et
35 ans nous sortons de l'ena au mois de
mai nous ne voulons pas limiter notre
choix la fonction publique tous nous
avons accueillis à l'ena une solide un
solide esprit d'organisation une bonne
maîtrise des techniques de gestion et
une expérience concrète de la décision
très bien on n'a rien appris quoi au
juste appris la être des chefs
cette petite annonce était une façon de
dire arrêtons d'être hypocrite si on a
fait l'ena c'est pas pour être
fonctionnaire c'est pour cesser pour
ressembler à l'élite qui aux élites
c'est pour gouverner c'est pour diriger
c'est pour gagner du pognon c'est pour
profiter et c'est évidemment un bon et
c'était une façon c'était une façon de
le dire explicitement à l'ena cette pub
fait l'effet d'une bombe
au même moment nicolas théry qui prépare
le concours d'entrée est choqué
offrez-vous un énarque ça a déboulé
comme j'étais en troisième année de
sciences po donc juste un an d'un avant
de tenter le concours et ça a été un
vrai choc c'est à dire que là on a eu le
sentiment d'une trahison parce que on a
eu le sentiment d'utilisation d'une
scolarité à laquelle nous on aspirait
terriblement on avait très très envie de
réussir le concours et en avais pas
envie de l'associer à aller travailler
immédiatement dans le privé et je pense
que ce basculement des années 80 ils
expliquent beaucoup de la critique
aujourd'hui de l'ena parce que c'était
un basculement où la logique d'état la
logique collective s'est amenuisé sous
les coups de butoir de la révolution
néolibérale et évidemment ça s'est senti
sur l'ena comme ça s'est senti sur tous
les secteurs de la haute fonction
publique et surtout les secteurs des
étudiants c'est le moment où finalement
les le sentiment de destins individuels
a prévalu sur les logiques collectives
un changement de logiciel qui coïncide
bientôt avec le retour de la droite au
pouvoir
1986 pour la seconde fois jacques chirac
entre à matignon c'est la cohabitation
des privatisations pour commencer
edouard balladur le nouveau ministre de
l'économie et chargé de les mener à bien
avec ces privatisations le pantouflage
qui consiste pour des hauts
fonctionnaires aller travailler dans le
privé on cesse définitivement d'être
rentable et s'accélère
décomplexés
plus en plus dès lors qu rejoignent le
secteur privé et c'est là que à mon avis
de l'évolution la plus grave se produit
quand on a reproché à l'ena de conquérir
des places en politique c'était c'était
juste et ça a été aussi une forme de
deux de détournement de ce que devait
être l'école ça me paraît beaucoup plus
grave en termes de déontologie et en
terme donc de conception même de l'école
que de savoir qu'une partie de ces
élèves vont devenir des cadres et des
dirigeants du secteur privé les n'avait
pas été créé pour ça en cette fin des
années 80 l'image de l'ena c'est donc
tergnier pourtant réalité seule une
petite partie des énarques pantoufles
hier comme aujourd'hui la grande
majorité d'entre eux continuent à
travailler dans l'administration pour
des salaires qui sont loin de ceux des
grands patrons du privé de façon
générale il ya très peu
d'anciens élèves qui vont dans le
secteur privé la 15 à 20 % d'élèves qui
au cours de leur carrière
vends une ou deux fois dans le secteur
privé mais je crois qu'il ya moins de 7
à 8 % d'élèves qu'ils vont
définitivement dans le privé alors on
peut leur reprocher en disant mais au
fond ces élèves ils ont choisi services
d'état ils n'ont pas choisi de services
du secteur privé c'est vrai c'est pas
interdit par la loi
donc c'est pas le sujet de l'ena c'est
le législateur qui pourrait l'interdire
l'a jamais interdit mais le mal est fait
dans l'esprit du grand public
les énarques sont assimilés au
pantouflage et aux carrières facile
françois mitterrand estime qu'il faut
entreprendre des réformes pour
réconcilier l'ena avec les français en
1983 déjà avec anis et le port son
ministre de la fonction publique
il avait créé une troisième voie ouverte
aux syndicalistes et responsables
d'associations un moyen de diversifier
le recrutement
en 91 c'est edith cresson la nouvelle
première ministre qui est chargée d'agir
c'est la délocalisation à strasbourg
l'objectif est de reconnecter les
énarques avec le terrain
les élèves n'ont pas été consultés ils
ont le sentiment d'une injustice et
occupent symboliquement leur école en
signe de protestation
l'occasion pour eux de faire passer un
message au grand public comme aux
politiques qui se ferait une fausse
image bien on se bat à georges l'honneur
de me coucher sur la moc à
l'amphithéâtre jean moulin mais
c'est de montrer la même pression que
loin d'être coupée la réalité sociale de
ce pays ne pouvait avoir des prix que
des préoccupations theater le grand
public ne connaît mal sinon il serait
qu'on n'est pas des polars entrave à
théo weston mac os en train de croiser
dans la rue
au sommaire des hommes et des femmes
comme tout le monde comme disait ma
camarade les narcos un père une mère
j'espère que tout le monde en est
conscient
les tout jeunes valérie pécresse futur
ministre a elle aussi son sac de
couchage ce qu ils soient délocalisés
l'ena à strasbourg c'est comme dire
aujourd'hui qu'on veut la supprimer
c'est quelque part offrir un totem
montrait qu'on veut faire quelque chose
contre les élites ou la vôtre fonction
publique plutôt que de réformer
effectivement l'état
une faute de réformes en profondeur le
désamour entre les français et leur
école d'administration grandi
chaque jour les énarques incarne un peu
plus ses élites rendu responsable de
tous les nas et la culture du nom risque
de l'indécision l'ena c'est la culture
de l'échec l'ena c'est la première école
de trafic d'influencé et les bras c'est
un énorme gâchis de talents
les intellectuels comme le sociologue
pierre bourdieu critique de au silicone
se débarrasser de la de la pensée
anarchiste fait de ce mode de pensée
haute arrogant bureaucratique lointain
finalement le problème de la haute
fonction publique française qui
alimentent la critique des élites
politico administratives et plus
généralement de l'ena c'est cette
question de l'administration à deux
vitesses où on a d'un côté des grands
corps qui monopolisent les positions de
pouvoir et qui sont effectivement très
puissant au sommet d administration et
d'autre part la grande masse des
énarques qui embrassent des carrières
beaucoup plus discrètes au sein des
administrations centrales près de 90%
des anciens de l'ena travaillent dans
l'ombre sans que l'on entende jamais
parler d'eux ce qui pantouflent où selon
ce temps politique sont une minorité qui
la plupart du temps et issus des grands
corps c'est elle qui en grande partie
brouiller l'image de l'école élu
président de la république en 2007
nicolas sarkozy va tenter de régler le
problème
comme mitterrand il n'est pas énarque
mais avocat de formation
un itinéraire devenu rare dans les
hautes sphères du pouvoir et dont lui
même sa muse et c'est quand j'étais
ministre des finances j'ai une équipe
fantastique qui alors un jour j'ai
regardé de recul que invités puis mon
vous m'en voyez pas louise mais celui
qui est pas fait polytechnique elena
c'est qu'il a vu un chagrin d'amour
immense il y avait un truc qui s'était
passé dans ma famille je n'ai pas fait
l'ena j'ai pas fait polytechnique
un an après son élection le nouveau
président de la république s'attaque à
la réforme de l'ena
sarkozy trouvé très injuste et très
inégalitaire que une personne qui a eu
un concours à 25 ans à 22 ans qui
sortent le premier de l'école que jamais
sa carrière n'est remise en cause il
peut aller dans une grande entreprise
échoué et revenir à la cour des comptes
ou à l'instruction des finances au
conseil d'état sans qu'on puisse lui
demander des comptes
il peut même échoué en étant patron d'un
grand d'une grande admission seule
administration centrale et et revenir
dans son corps d'origine pour mieux
repartir sert qu'à la limite finalement
ces corps vous ces grands corps fredonne
une virginité pour mieux repartir si
vous aviez échoué en septembre 2009
nicolas sarkozy fait pas sans décret qui
supprime le fameux classement de sortie
mais la riposte s'organise deux mois
plus tard le conseil d'état se
débrouille pour annuler le texte j'ai du
juge et partie donc ce convoqué étaient
concernés quand vous quand vous avez un
décret qui peut remettre en cause de qui
vous êtes ce que vous êtes
je sais pas s'ils ont été totalement
objectif dans le dans la remise en cause
du décret mais ça c'est mon point de vue
très personnel
le principal
acteur veto dans les réformes
d'administration sont les grands corps
qui bénéficient de la manière dont
s'organise la haute administration et
qui n'ont absolument pas intérêt à ce
qu'on remette en question la
hiérarchisation entre eux et le reste de
l'administration
ils n'ont absolument pas intérêt à ce
que les carrières se déroule de manière
plus égalitaire en 2012 françois
hollande et c'est à son tour de réformer
le système
contrairement à son prédécesseur le
nouveau président est un ancien élève de
l'ena
il est même issu d'une promotion rester
dans l'histoire la promo voltaire elle
compte un président un premier ministre
dominique de villepin
une candidate à la présidentielle
ségolène royal
plusieurs ministres dont frédérique
bredin renaud donnedieu de vabres michel
sapin
32 ans après l'ena françois hollande
pourtant sorti dans la botte estime lui
aussi qu'il faut modifier les règles
d'accès direct aux grands corps moi je
suis comme on dit bien sortie de lainage
parthenay à la cour des comptes et je
n'ai jamais eu comme président de la
république la volonté de servir la
maison qui m'avait accueilli tu trouvais
que c'était
c'était pas du tout de mon de mon
ressort que d'avoir comme ça une
reconnaissance ou une récompense à
l'égard d'une institution moi j'avais
pensé qu' il fallait qu'il y ait plus
d'accès direct aux grands corps a sorti
de l'ena
finalement on rentrera dans ces corps là
qu'une fois qu'on aura une expansion
administratives les grands corps se sont
eux-mêmes mobilisés pour qu' il n'y ait
pas cette cette possibilité de réformes
et parce qu'il n'y a pas eu cette
possibilité de réformes selena qu'on a
mis en cause complètement en empêchant
toute réforme
les grands corps prennent le risque de
saborder l'ina
car aux yeux de l'opinion leurs membres
apparaissent comme un clan une caste qui
se soutient et défend ses privilèges
face à eux les politiques manquent de
courage
comment sortir de l'impasse un énarque
va leur prendre une décision radicale et
porter le coup de grâce à son ancienne
école nous sommes en 2019
emmanuel macron et président de la
république entre les nae lui pourtant
tout avait bien commencé
promotion senghor emmanuel macron est
sorti dans la botte
mais après quatre années à l'inspection
des finances il a été débauché par la
banque rothschild
un pot to flash qui passe mal dans une
partie de pignol
en pleine crise et gilet jaune l'image
de beauxis lui colle à la peau
[Musique]
assimiler à ses élites qu'une partie des
français ne supporteraient plus en avril
emmanuel macron créer la surprise il
faut supprimer entre autres l'ena mais
pas pour se donner le plaisir de
supprimer les noms je ne crois pas du
tout en quelque sorte aux rafistolages à
la réforme un peu ça déjà été tentée par
à peu près tous mes prédécesseurs
on va changer le classement de sortie
ont échangé nancy vous garder les mêmes
structures les habitudes sont trop
fortes les habitus sont là macron il
réforme rien alors qu'il est arrivé pour
réformer mais il se rend compte que
c'est impossible de réformer très
difficile qui donne un sentiment de
bouger aujourd'hui m'ont informé bon bah
on va casser on va réformer l'ena et
puis on dira mais voyez gérer formule
pour de nombreux énorme
cette décision est une trahison certes
l'école n'est pas parfaite mais elle a
en grande partie rempli sa mission
elle a mis fin la cooptation et au
népotisme les hauts fonctionnaires
quelle forme
son noyau est compétent seul son
recrutement peine à se démocratiser
même si avec 29 % d'élèves boursiers les
n'a de cesse de faire des efforts
et
on nous dit l'ascenseur social est en
panne oui il est en panne d entre le
rez-de-chaussée et le premier étage
tout le monde sait bien que le système
éducatif français il est à ces
inégalités à l'ena n'est pas responsable
politique éducative sociale qui ont été
menées et qui font que tel ou tel élève
arrive à l'ena c'est sûr que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour un enfant
d'ouvrier à vivant dans une petite ville
d'arrivée n'a que pour un élève ayant
fréquenté les grands lycées parisiens et
des dépôts établissements universitaires
mais lena n'est pas responsable de cette
situation
enel a qu'une envie c'est de recevoir
ses élèves
le vrai sujet c'est que les enfants de
toutes catégories sociales de toutes
origines se dé gilet jaune ceux de l'est
du nord du sud de l'ouest puissent
accéder à l'ena les enfants d'ouvriers
d'employés comme ceux de cadres
supérieurs supprimer les nains est ce
bien la solution à droite comme à gauche
ancien élève ou non beaucoup estiment
que l'école n'a pas démérité je suis
opposé la suppression de l'ena mais je
suis totalement opposé et d'ailleurs
j'en avais fait part emmanuel macron je
trouve que c'est une erreur
on peut améliorer cette école mais ça
reste une école d'excellence elle est
devenue une école élitiste et donc on
peut corriger cet élitisme
mais supprimer cette école je vous dire
on remplace par quoi remplace par diffus
différents parcours des entretiens
moi je trouve que là on va réintégrer
une plus grande inégalité pour tous ces
français qui s'interroge sur sciemment
l'élitisme et donc l'éloignement de
de l'état par rapport à leur vie je leur
dirai je vous comprends mais ne vous
trompez pas de cible
ce qu'il faut c'est réformer la
démocratie il faut changer un certain
nombre de deux rapports institutionnels
faut vous consulter davantage des
français tout est centralisé des
décisions il faudra toujours qui est des
fonctionnaires qui qui assument leur
tâche aura toujours qu'il y ait des gens
plutôt bien formés qui prennent des
décisions
je ne pense pas que la suppression d'un
nas ou à la solution parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on mettra à la place
comment recrutera ton les hauts
fonctionnaires encore une fois si l'état
n'a plus besoin de d'être service il n'y
a plus besoin de serviteurs sont là on
peut aller a sorti des business school
recruter ceux qui feront les retours sur
investissement le plus rapide depuis sa
nomination en 2017
le directeur de l'ena se démène pour
sauver l'école en réformant sa scolarité
c'est un jean p m
épreuve pratique évaluation des
compétences et non plus seulement des
connaissances
côté élèves la notion d'engagement
semble trouver un nouveau souffle en ces
temps incertains pour beaucoup d'entre
eux intégrer l'ena est un moyen d'agir
sur le monde
jamais depuis dix ans l'école n'a reçu
autant de candidatures
selon as on est une génération qui est
fondamentalement habité par la question
du sens au travail ce qui prépare et que
nationale d'administration après je
pense qu'ils sont beaucoup plus proches
en effet de la génération de 1945 et de
ses de cette croyance forte dans le fait
que c'est l'état qui va nous permettre
d'affronter aujourd'hui les plus gros
enjeux mondiaux en matière
environnementale sanitaire en matière de
stabilité financière en matière de
de démographie des défis démographiques
aujourd'hui que your février 2021 alors
qu'il rencontre des étudiants
emmanuel macron semble faire machine
arrière plus question de supprimer l'ena
il choisit d'en modifier l'accès afin de
favoriser la diversité
mais deux mois plus tard nouveau coup de
théâtre
finalement le président annonce la
fermeture définitive de l'école elle
sera remplacée par un institut unique
qui formera à tous les métiers de la
haute fonction publique ou politique ou
révolution profonde
cette nouvelle école parviendra-t-elle
enfants à réconcilier les français avec
leurs élites
[Musique]
mais
où
[Musique]